thank you for your wonderful lecture mr.
de montebello I wanted to come back to
what you told us about your students in
New York and you said well they have no
money but they do have iPads and the
wonderful thing about the iPads is that
it brings you any collection from any
museum anywhere in the world
very close because just lately I was
looking at the collections of the
Metropolitan and I was amazed that I
could see all these details because they
have photographed the objects and you
can really zoom up close much closer
than you were ever able to see it in the
vtrene in the museum and also with the
iPad you can hop around and any
information that you might not have you
can look it up because it is available
so perhaps that's why this younger
generation doesn't feel the need for
this broad general knowledge that we in
our 50s and 60s and maybe our 40s have
acquired in our education and also tied
into what the lady in front said about
young people not wanting to accumulate
stuff but wanting to accumulate
experiences and this is what you can do
with your iPad and then of course the
best part would be to combine it with
actually physically being there in front
of the work of art and seeing the paint
and smelling maybe some dust but the
more physical experience that hits you
in the gut as you mentioned earlier let
it be understood first that the answer
is coming from someone who does not own
an iPad on the other hand I don't know
what connection you have with Apple
but I have access on my dell computer to
the Prados website to the Bruegel's in
the consistory stress museum and now to
that astonishing website of the Ghent
Altarpiece with something like 20,000
pixels per square centimeter of the
Ghent Altarpiece you you've raised an
extremely interesting question let me
first before I give you the positive
side let me use my French character of
being right away a hollow and cold which
is to say that you are experiencing
nothing you are you are looking at
simulacra you can only experience an
original because the simulacrum no
matter how wonderful it is this lacks
the virtue of authenticity by which I
mean when you are in the Prado let's say
and you're standing in front of the
meninas part of and I and I will grant
you that today you can probably recreate
with a certain number of pixels and even
imitating the matière of the surface
almost pretty much the identical picture
in the room next door the difference
will be in your mind subconsciously that
as you approach the main enos the real
one you will have a sense that you have
stepped back in history that you will be
in the presence of the very work that
was in the bedroom of Philip the fourth
that he made even of caressed and
touched that this is the work it was not
made out of pixels I'm not a
psychiatrist or psychologist and so
forth but there is something that
happens in your mind that absolutely
changes you when you are in confronting
the original object the other aspect of
it and you bring up something very
interesting
the I have been fascinated by these
extraordinary images that many of you
have also seen of enormous magnification
of details and friend of mine was a
critic in Paris he's alive therefore I
don't remember his name right now is
about to do at the second edition of a
book on the way to Calvary by Bruegel in
in Vienna for the extraordinary details
and he sent me some of those details and
I must say I I was enormous ly excited
by them and then it occurred to me that
I was seeing something Bruegel may not
have expected who wanted me to see
because your eye and mine do not have a
zoom lens they don't and so are we in a
sense cheating but it's cheating
necessarily wrong if the reaction I
received in looking at the Ghent
Altarpiece so in looking at the way to
Calvary of Pieter Bruegel the elder was
such an exciting experience and then
appeared to me if what the truth was
which is that the way to Calvary was
painted for the Archduke of Habsburg and
he had it in his apartments and he had
it day after day after day and every day
he spent minutes doesn't need to be more
than that most of you don't spend more
than 15 seconds in front of a picture
time yourselves in a museum and he had a
lifetime to look and find all of the
details and I go back to what I said
earlier in my lecture the whole thing is
an issue of time and the problem is in
museums we simply do not ever give it
the time I will never forget when I've
one of my first visit to the Frick when
I was a student in New York with that
sublime painting of Saint Francis by
Bellini in the wilderness
and I stood in front of that picture
just forever
I was just looking at every detail
looking at the whole going back and
forth and at one point from the corner
of my eye I saw the guard began to
approach me and I must have been there
maybe ten minutes which is an eternity
in a museum and the God came up to me
and said sir what are you doing but the
issue of the magnified detail and the
pleasure we take out of it is is a very
interesting metaphysical one and it's
one I continue to think about I have no
answer but all I can say is that I find
them absolutely a delight